[SPEAKER_00]: All right, evening of the third of Wellsun, after the adventurers come back to Monmurg on the Kosair.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's night time.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You and Merrick are summoned to Lord James's chambers, or his...
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically, his office is in the Harvard District.
[SPEAKER_01]: Quite familiar with it then.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: You've been there many times.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, that's where he does most of his business when it comes to security and then other things, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And he wants to talk to you and Merrick separately.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, you're first.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, you're escorted into James' office and basically sat down opposite him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gouge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there liquor in the office?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, always.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will just go over.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm pretty sure by now I can go help myself.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm going to go over and pour a glass and sit at the desk.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not as good shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: The sea shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: The stuff you recognize.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because there's some stuff there you do not recognize.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hey, the rougher the better, so.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I go for the cheapest bottle.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which he would probably appreciate and doesn't care, so yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Report.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, Paul made it back safely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you for that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Barely safely.
[SPEAKER_00]: Was it his performance that was in question?
[SPEAKER_00]: Was he vainglorious?
[SPEAKER_01]: He
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, he's got a definite entitlement to him, which I'm going to have to say he's entitled to.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, his performance was okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I haven't really figured him out.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's definitely an interesting youth.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's inexperienced, there's no doubt about it.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I'm wondering, and what I want to know, is if that can be knocked off with time and experience.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think so.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think the chip on his shoulder will probably be chiseled down with a little more experience and getting put into his place.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, I didn't push anything too hard with him and just because obviously he had me watching him and he is the nephew and I think I can work a little harder on him next time now that I know how thick his skin is.
[SPEAKER_01]: There was no conflict between you and he then?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Didn't have a conflict.
[SPEAKER_01]: He seemed respectable to me, which I'll take.
[SPEAKER_01]: He did have some insight into some of the doings that I'll report on that
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know how well I can trust on what he told us if that's exactly what happened, exactly the way it went.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviously there was a lot more shit going down as you had imagined or suspected as opposed to the king like, ugh, fine, send someone to the look.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think his lackadaisical view into this is questionable.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't want to overstep my bounds, just from what was there, what we encountered, which you had an idea of, no idea why he wasn't more concerned.
[SPEAKER_00]: He and Fairwind are actually very good friends.
[SPEAKER_00]: He wouldn't want to think ill of his friend, and this is the truth of it, Gouge.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, however I...
[SPEAKER_00]: My eye has to be completely objective in these things.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it's been a while now that I've been looking at Fairwind and his jealousy of Prince Gian and his jealousy of Monmurg in general.
[SPEAKER_00]: As you know, there are negotiations and political maneuverings happening between the Toli, but also between the princes of the Outer Isles.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fairwind is
[SPEAKER_00]: The most outspoken, and I think that Jian would consider giving him his wishes.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are things Jian is, what I will say, very intent on, seen happen in this country.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he's willing to spend political capital on it.
[SPEAKER_00]: My personal view is that it's not worth it.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is, in a way, kind of what you just said.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why is he blinded by these things?
[SPEAKER_00]: He is an idealist, and that's the problem, actually, in this case.
[SPEAKER_00]: The princes of the Outer Isles are not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I can sum up the best of what we experienced there.
[SPEAKER_01]: We landed on the... What side that was?
[SPEAKER_01]: The Southern...
[SPEAKER_01]: The Southern Lighthouse.
[SPEAKER_01]: Southern Beacon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Landed there with a...
[SPEAKER_01]: I got the maps right under that, I think.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, we landed... Just a second one here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, landed on the Southern Beacon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sent the ship around, landed with, I think, 30 or so of us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Upon coming up onto it, were met with hobgoblins at the bridge tower, which we were able to take and secure, and left the men and the Marine captain, the Navy captain that you sent us with, he stayed there.
[SPEAKER_01]: We didn't take the hobgoblins out of the barracks.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was kind of at a standstill with that point.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think anything else happened.
[SPEAKER_01]: We didn't head that far south, so I'm not sure what the men are doing there now.
[SPEAKER_01]: But we made our way through the forest with Merrick Lettuce all the way up to, let me see here, the barracks.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do believe it's where we met Captain Steve and others who explained some more things.
[SPEAKER_01]: We know the secret entrance.
[SPEAKER_01]: We didn't take that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm trying to sum this up.
[SPEAKER_01]: The guys in the barracks, they were able to put out a diversion which allowed us to go around to the back side of the helm to try to find Fairwin.
[SPEAKER_01]: And tried to see if we could figure out the secret entrance.
[SPEAKER_01]: Into the helm, which we really couldn't tell, but we did see a new type of Corsair ship being loaded by a skiff coming out from underneath the helm.
[SPEAKER_01]: This new ship is not one of our making.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's one of that we've, I think, seen from the far east.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's, I think, the ship called the Sea Ghost.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've had reports of it.
[SPEAKER_00]: What was this?
[SPEAKER_00]: Kane Toole.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hey, Casey.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm home now and should be home the rest of the night.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm in no hurry.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, that does.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I do, plus more stuff my dad brought if you're curious.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, perfect.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: She's coming to re-bandage my finger.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hopefully it's not going to fall off.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, from on-wall for that ship, which is not common for us.
[SPEAKER_01]: We don't have that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, I think our shipyards are starting to emulate that, and I believe the Seaghost actually was purchased by the Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Particularly Kane Toli.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that makes sense, because the Toli were on it.
[SPEAKER_01]: We made our way...
[SPEAKER_01]: Into the helm.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hobgoblins were in control of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: The diversion worked.
[SPEAKER_01]: We snuck in.
[SPEAKER_01]: We got as far as the Inner Sanctum to try to find Ferwin.
[SPEAKER_01]: He was found by Paul's Lizard.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that's the part where I... Paul's Lizard?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, he's got some...
[SPEAKER_01]: A homoculin or something he called it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know what it is.
[SPEAKER_00]: A homoculus?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he called it that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like I said, I really don't know how to take him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll speak with Jude about this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: To identify that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I am aware of what a homoculus is.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, he sent that in and he picked up a conversation where he told us that Ferwin was talking with Tuttoli, making a deal on something, and Ferwin wasn't under duress.
[SPEAKER_01]: He was actively making a deal with the Tullis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Upon our diversion, with Jude and his toad taking the hobgoblin out, it created a little bit of a ruckus, and we engaged the Toli with Ferwin.
[SPEAKER_01]: We defeated, we killed one of the Toli, we captured another, and we captured and tied up Ferwin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who was not happy with this, that obviously asked me why, and all we had to go off of was Paul's, you're lying, I heard you, I know what you're doing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nobody else witnessed what Pharaoh was saying.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, just...
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, just Paul.
[SPEAKER_00]: Through this magical device.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: This magical creature.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, saw it through its eyes and was able to pick up on the conversation.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ferwin tried to play it like when we got to him, he was tied up.
[SPEAKER_01]: We do believe he tied himself up to pretend that he was not working with them, that he was having to, being forced to, due to threats.
[SPEAKER_01]: We decided to take them down below the secret passage and get to what we discovered were barrels of some type of mixture of sand that's been sprinkled into the water that keeps the sahagin away.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's not some spell or fog that's kept them away.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's this manufactured chemical that's used.
[SPEAKER_01]: And these barrels were being taken by the Toli.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fairwind said himself he has his own fair stash back at his keep or area.
[SPEAKER_01]: But they were going to be removing, from what we could tell, everything from Helm Island.
[SPEAKER_01]: Meaning there was no way to salt the sea to keep the sahagin from coming into here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not sure why, not sure what's going on with that.
[SPEAKER_01]: We lost the captured Toli, actually was killed because when we were trying to make our way out we were attacked and Jude immediately just
[SPEAKER_01]: Took care of him and kicked him over into the water which was filled with sharks maybe run or with a sahagin.
[SPEAKER_01]: There was an extremely large, large shark in there.
[SPEAKER_01]: We confirmed that the Toli, well we found his arm floating so we're pretty sure he didn't make it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then the Bard Folsom was in control of Fairwin.
[SPEAKER_01]: And upon this ledge when we were going around the chasm to get to this spot, Paul tried to get around them to get up to us.
[SPEAKER_01]: And in doing so was kicked off the ledge into the water by Farwin.
[SPEAKER_00]: So Farwin actually attacked Paul Ribeiro.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, he was not attacking Folsom.
[SPEAKER_01]: Folsom had him under his charm.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know,
[SPEAKER_01]: Farron was fine to talk to, arrogant, typical.
[SPEAKER_01]: He conversed with me.
[SPEAKER_01]: He was...
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: He said, I've got information, so I've got a part in this that I can play.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not the captor here.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he was very, very not happy with being treated in that manner.
[SPEAKER_01]: Our plan was to bring him back here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did he admit to anything?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, he admitted having the barrels of this.
[SPEAKER_00]: So he admitted removing barrels.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviously, I believe he was lying to try to cover his own ass in this.
[SPEAKER_01]: He denied being in with the tollies on this to us, but we had to go with Paul and trust Paul's judgment on this and take it for what it was since
[SPEAKER_01]: He is the nephew and I don't think he's skilled enough or enough to be part of something that we have to worry about.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, that did cross my mind.
[SPEAKER_01]: She sent me to watch him, so I didn't go off anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't think he's an agent or anything like that?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's doubtful that he would betray Lord Gena and Prince Gena.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: It did cross my mind, but I found it quite doubtful due to his youthfulness.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, this might just be more his attitude that maybe kind of gave me that hint of it, but I don't feel that there's anything with there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I believe he is doing something to what we don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why would you take away the protection of the island at this time?
[SPEAKER_01]: We're blockaded.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're not getting supplies into Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he was quite aware of that and didn't seem to have any type of worry about that either.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he also went into the water, into the chasm there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude got Paul out with levitation.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was going to go in after him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Luckily I didn't because it was
[SPEAKER_01]: Way more sharks than we were expecting in there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Got him out, but a fair one we have no trace of.
[SPEAKER_01]: We don't have any body and we didn't find any trace of him escaping, although there was a passageway that led out to the eastern side.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do believe it was Jude saw footprints.
[SPEAKER_01]: He'll be able to tell you more about that, although we didn't see any wet footprints or any water from that area that he would have been completely wet in.
[SPEAKER_01]: But Jude did that on his own under invisibility when we were preparing everything to leave.
[SPEAKER_01]: We couldn't bring him back.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what we were going to do for proper interrogation.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know how that would have went.
[SPEAKER_01]: Probably would have had to bring him in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Would have had to keep him in hiding and come to you to find out how we needed to bring him in.
[SPEAKER_01]: That probably wouldn't have looked good anywhere.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that would have been the plan, but not having him.
[SPEAKER_01]: We were lucky to get out of there.
[SPEAKER_01]: We sprinkled the water on our way out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Merrick could buy some sailing raft that got us back out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did great with that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, the Navy guys that you had there were quite capable.
[SPEAKER_00]: They told me that you had 23 of the barrels when you returned.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that all?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, there were... You had four on the ship, but there are 23 that are supposedly still...
[SPEAKER_00]: I think there was 25 altogether.
[SPEAKER_01]: When we took four and the others were left.
[SPEAKER_00]: So there's 21 still back at home.
[SPEAKER_00]: I do believe...
[SPEAKER_00]: I thought there was 21 left.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, and...
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't tell anybody what the stuff was or how it worked, and I'm not sure what the ship that went back to the island, if anyone told them.
[SPEAKER_01]: They might have told them to use it, but not what it was.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I don't know who was in charge with that when we got back to who had those barrels, but it wasn't me.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I did.
[SPEAKER_01]: Protected Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: Observed.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I got from it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul saw more.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like I said, nobody can verify the conversation with the Tolis and Fairwin.
[SPEAKER_01]: No one can verify that he actually wasn't tied up.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we're going on Paul's word with that.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, Gian sent Paul and said, don't let him know what's going on.
[SPEAKER_01]: But Paul seemed angry enough.
[SPEAKER_01]: And unedged enough to even maybe expose himself or just...
[SPEAKER_01]: When Fairwin was saying, what?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul was just angry and...
[SPEAKER_01]: I think being youthful, his emotion took charge, so I took that as a more truthful thing than Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just playing it off was like, you're wrong.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is not how this goes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul was upset.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're a liar.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm like, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which tells me that's truth coming because he can't hold it in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, honestly...
[SPEAKER_00]: The fact that Lord Fairwind admitted the fact that he had been removing barrels from Helm Island, that right there is an indication of betrayal, actually.
[SPEAKER_00]: The barrels of that substance is a state secret.
[SPEAKER_00]: The dwindling supply that we have is very precious to us.
[SPEAKER_00]: The fact that he removed that from the island itself, it sounds like he admitted to taking it to Fairwind Island.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: He has his own personal stash at Fairwind Island and was allowing the Toli to take the other.
[SPEAKER_00]: This shows that he is interested in defending his own island in these days.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will let you know this.
[SPEAKER_00]: 150 years ago, the Sea Principalities was able to form as a political entity because of an alliance between the Duke of Berghoff and the pirates of the Outer Islands.
[SPEAKER_00]: The biggest scourge in the Azure Sea, of course, is the Hagen Kingdoms, and there was a huge one.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the bay, just north of our coastline.
[SPEAKER_00]: They raided all the coast, from here to the Dragon Isles, Red Shore, Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: The kind of trade that we have now would not have been possible at that time because of the influence of the sahuagin.
[SPEAKER_00]: They were the true rulers of the sea at that point.
[SPEAKER_01]: There was a book that Merrick ended up with that I read on the sailing back that talked to the history of how they decimated the undersea worlds as well and created all this.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I got some information from that book that you'll probably want to ask Merrick about.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've read that history, actually, and it's not a history that's very well known.
[SPEAKER_00]: Admiral Flotsam wrote that maybe 50 years ago.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he wrote it as a warning because at that time the Duke of Berghof quit giving us the yellow substance.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically he said that it was no longer required.
[SPEAKER_00]: We had a huge store of it on Helm Island.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Outer Islands had huge stores of it as well and actually there was a fortress in the center of the bay north of us.
[SPEAKER_00]: That fortress is mentioned in the book that has the greatest store possible.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was actually the staging grounds of our war with the Sahuagin and the Uzzurri.
[SPEAKER_00]: Boats would regularly go over the cities of the Sahuagin with barrels of the stuff and dump them into the ocean.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hundreds of thousands of Sahuagin were killed 150 years ago and it was what allowed
[SPEAKER_00]: Our nation to prosper.
[SPEAKER_00]: Keoland, for its part, benefited from our efforts, but also after we became a nation and started to have conflict with Keoland, they used our practices against the Sahuagin as a political reason to
[SPEAKER_00]: Engage the Ulic States against us.
[SPEAKER_00]: You see, the yellow powder is not only damaging to the fish and wildlife and seabed.
[SPEAKER_00]: It strips everything clean.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so the elves and other demihumans of the Ulic States saw our acts as far too destructive.
[SPEAKER_00]: We pulled back from those activities.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, we maintained our salting around Monmurg and certain strategic areas so the sahuagin would not come back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Recently, within the last decade,
[SPEAKER_00]: We've gotten to the point where so much of the substance is not available to us that we've had to pull back greatly.
[SPEAKER_00]: And because of that, sahuagin have re-entered the area quite a bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is one of the points that we have been negotiating with the Duke of Berkhoff on.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, he's not interested.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And...
[SPEAKER_00]: Recently, the lease on the fort in the middle of the bay, Salingmore Bay, as it's called,
[SPEAKER_00]: Expired and Kane Toli took the island over.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is where most of our stores of this substance are available at this point in time.
[SPEAKER_00]: At first he did not deny us the shipments that we would take there for various purposes.
[SPEAKER_00]: But this winter he did, basically cutting off all supply to it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically saying that the Duke of Perth had told the Toli that they were no longer supposed to give the Outer Isles any of this, which is a life force for us.
[SPEAKER_00]: This coincides with
[SPEAKER_00]: The activities of the Duke of Gratzel, his blockading of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: And what I've heard is his interaction with the Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's been some communication between the Duke of Gratzel and Prince Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's even been talk of an alliance between the two, which
[SPEAKER_00]: Historically it's very strange because they've been nothing but at odds for hundreds of years.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who was making the substance?
[SPEAKER_01]: Not Gratzel.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: Even though Gratzel purports to have a very, very advanced school of transmutation as part of their
[SPEAKER_00]: Magical academies.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I have no doubt there are adequate transmuters there.
[SPEAKER_00]: None of them equal the knowledge of the Duke of Berghof.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just wondered why would the Toli be working with Fairwind to take barrels off if they had access to barrels through an alliance elsewhere?
[SPEAKER_01]: To deny it to us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So almost a direct attack on Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fairwind's activities, I think, are because of his jealousy of the
[SPEAKER_00]: Success of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you look at all of the princes, Iridian princes, Monmurg has benefited the most from the alliance with the Plars.
[SPEAKER_00]: The wealth that comes through Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: The taxes generated, the trade generated, far outstrips, anything the Outer Isles have.
[SPEAKER_00]: And even though they still engage in piracy, it's not nearly as beneficial as the trade that Prince Gion engaged.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gion has completely given up piracy of a nautical sort and now just relies on piracy of a moneylender sort.
[SPEAKER_01]: He really wasn't lying from his aspect and his view of, you know, I'm not going against the principalities here.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, I'm along with all of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Monmurg, you guys are the ones that are really the one against all of us.
[SPEAKER_01]: He said that.
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just thinking that he didn't seem to have much love for Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Again, he's friends with Jian.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, I believe that there is something two-fold going on here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fairwind, even though he is a friend of Jian's and they have been friends for many years, his jealousy of the success of Monmurg and also his objection to Prince Jian's political pressure are
[SPEAKER_00]: Both at play.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Berling probably has a very good point with regards to negotiations with the Toli and the Duke of Berghoff.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have a feeling the reason the Duke of Berghoff is restricting the barrels of the substance to us is because of Prince Gian's
[SPEAKER_00]: Attempts to eliminate the slave trade from the media jungle.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's been petitioning for quite some time to disallow and stop.
[SPEAKER_00]: Any kind of slave trading in the sea principalities and to limit Prince Toli's ability to go to the Imedo jungle and take the wealth there.
[SPEAKER_00]: The slaves, the ivory, the gold that he finds there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know if you know this, but that's where the Toli get most of their wealth.
[SPEAKER_00]: Raiding the tribes in the Imedo jungle.
[SPEAKER_00]: There is gold, there's ivory, there's wood, and obviously that's part of the wealth, but they go mainly there for the slaves.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they trade with the rest of O-Earth in that human capital.
[SPEAKER_00]: John finds this distasteful and actually, in truth, he would eliminate it in Monmurg if he could.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, Berghoff and the Toli benefit too much from this trade and they're willing to risk our alliance and he then exposes to the Duke of Gratzel to bring Gion back in line.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think Fairwind's point is understandable.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's afraid of
[SPEAKER_00]: Upsetting the Duke of Berghoff, as it were.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's argued this many times in council meetings.
[SPEAKER_00]: Unfortunately, this latest move endangers all of us, especially at a time when Gratzel is doing so well against us.
[SPEAKER_00]: Kane Toli is another matter.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I think the betrayal of the Tolis goes far beyond
[SPEAKER_00]: What Fairwind is doing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fairwind is looking to broker a peace and gain some gold.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what I believe his wishes are.
[SPEAKER_00]: I believe his actions are betrayal, personally, to the Sea Principalities and to Prince Gian as well, but I understand his motivation.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Toli's motivation I do not yet fully understand, and I think that
[SPEAKER_00]: They are the ones that are, through Caintoli, assisting the Duke of Gratzel in this war against us.
[SPEAKER_00]: About a month and a half ago, there was a wizard who visited
[SPEAKER_00]: You'll remember him.
[SPEAKER_00]: One of his associates hired you in Karmurg to guard him.
[SPEAKER_00]: This didn't happen to you, but I'll give you a summary of what it was.
[SPEAKER_00]: The one thing I wanted to know from this wizard was what did the Toli want?
[SPEAKER_00]: On the coast near Saltmarsh.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it turns out that Keaton only found an artifact there.
[SPEAKER_00]: A very powerful one.
[SPEAKER_00]: That I believe can control sea dragons.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the reason we have not been successful in our battles against...
[SPEAKER_00]: This is state secret, so don't tell this to anyone.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm telling it to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the reason I say this to you is, someday, I'm going to want you to go and get this artifact for me, if possible.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have to find an opportunity to do it, but Cain Toli, I believe, is our main enemy.
[SPEAKER_00]: It can control sea dragons and...
[SPEAKER_00]: When we go into combat with the Monmurgian Mana Wars, very often we'll see a storm off in the distance.
[SPEAKER_00]: A sure sign of Sea Dragons.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then, mysteriously, a few of our ships will go missing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Normally Sea Dragons
[SPEAKER_00]: Will not attack us.
[SPEAKER_00]: And definitely, for years, we've paid a yearly tribute to the Sea Dragons to allow the fleets to pass through.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sea Dragons are greedy, but gold buys them off.
[SPEAKER_00]: They have no wish to harm human beings, which they find not very tasty.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sahagin are much more to their taste.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fish, as it were.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like sardines to them.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I think Cain totally is using them against us.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or at least that's what I've been able to surmise from my discussions with this Lord Frank and other investigations and actually other conversations I've had with people that know of such things.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think Farrowind is a witless fool in this and doesn't know the true debt of this game that we're playing here or how dangerous it is, but his meddling cannot be ignored.
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely not.
[SPEAKER_00]: What door?